Hören Sie überall nur noch oder und sind Sie genervt von und?
Dann probieren Sie es doch jetzt mal mit Das Podcast UFO.
Das Podcast UFO, ein Podcast von Florentin Will und Stefan Tietze, garantiert für Spaß und bringt Sie durch den Alltag mit locker luftiger Unterhaltung.
Risiken und Nebenwirkungen fragen Sie die Polizei oder besuchen Sie worstbed.com. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge von Das Podcast Sofo mit mir, Stefan Tietze und dir, Floridin Wilder kriegt sich gar nicht mehr ein, der lacht sich. Ich mag Hub, ich mag so Geräusche, finde ich immer lustig. Wirklich, ich kann den traurigsten Film der Welt sehen, wenn vor meinem Fenster ein Auto hupt, lache ich. Ich bin einfach so einfach gepolt, ich bin einfach gestrickt, ich bin ein einfacher Typ. Aktion, Reaktion, lache ich, lache ich. Du lachst sofort, dich gruselig. Von daher vielen, vielen Dank für dieses Intro an Sina und Mala, die anscheinend den Zoo, den Bauernhof für sich entdeckt haben. Viel Spaß weiterhin damit. Ich denke, ihr werdet dann noch viele, viele
goldene Stunden haben. Und viel Geld mitverdienen. Wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr viel Geld. Wenn das Publikum ähnlich, weil ich meine, bei uns sind 50 Prozent von uns lieben diese Geräusche, wenn man das mal anwendet auf alle anderen Menschen. Der Lied ist an Markt auf jeden Fall, vielleicht für euch. Ich spiele Gitarre, ich spiele Flöte und Mahler spielt. Ich habe mir tatsächlich, wir hatten ja schon oft unsere Kategorie Dinge, die man nur aus Filmen kennt, existieren sie wirklich? Genau. Also eine unserer sperrigeren Rubriken. Die wir früh fallen gelassen haben, nur aufgrund des Titels. Inhaltlich knallert, aber niemand hat sich getraut, sie anzubilden, uns anzumoderierenieren, aber inhaltlich hat sie großen Spaß bereits. Ich würde sie gerne wieder ausgraben, noch einmal exhumieren. Dinge, die man nur aus Filmen kennt, gibt es sie wirklich? Und eines davon, die man zum Beispiel aus den Simpsons kennt, sind diese komischen Zylinder, die wenn man sie umdreht so und machen. Also diese Boxen, stell dir so. Das ist die Rubrik Dinge, die man nicht mal aus Filmen kennt. Doch, doch, doch, stell dir so eine schöne Öltjes-Erdnuss-Dose vor. Habe ich mir präsent vor Augen gestellt. Wenn du sie rotierst, oder ist da eine Kuh
drauf oder so. Gab es bei den
Simpsons Riesenlacher, habe ich mich
scheckig gelacht, dachte mir, das gibt es nicht wirklich.
Und habe es dann aber auf Amazon tatsächlich gefunden
und bestellt, einfach nur um zu sehen,
ob es das wirklich gibt, ob das
wirklich ankommt. Und hatte dann
tatsächlich so einen Becher, der
Mu gemacht hat, wenn man umgedreht hat. Enge Zielgruppe, ne?
Sehr, sehr enge Zielgruppe. Warum benutzt man das? Na ja, da ist ein Gewicht drin und das fährt dann so runter und es ist wie so ein Blasebalg, der dann so aber die konkrete Anwendung hält sich ja auch ein bisschen in Grenzen, das konkrete Einwendungsgebiet. Sehr, sehr eng. Steckt man das Anwendungsgebiet ab? Naja, also auf der einen Seite natürlich Kleinkinder, auf der anderen Seite Senioren. Senioren? Und alles, was dazwischen liegt, kann man eigentlich bespaßen. Du glaubst, Helga, 79, hat alles in dem Leben gesehen. Zweiter Weltkrieg kam und ging und die... Und dann einfach so eine Box, die so ähnlich klingt wie eine Flugsirene aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Das ist eine gute Idee. Ist die Tod vielleicht auch einfach, weil sie dann aus Angst stirbt. Tiere? Tiere sind sehr, sehr wütend. Außer Kühe. Aus der Kühe möglichst gar nicht. Aber gibt es da nicht irgendeine, ich glaube, so eine Simpsons-Folge, wo irgendwie das ganze Haus einstürzt und dann ganz am Ende steht nur noch ein Balken und der fällt um und dann dreht sich dieses Mooding um und dann so. Ja, wie gesagt, die Simpsons haben auch schon gesagt, das ist auch nicht mehr das, was sie mal waren. Oder sagen die Simpsons da wieder was, sind Trend voraus. Ay caramba, ja, kann auch sein, ja, stimmt schon, wenn das der Auslöser ist für irgendeinen großen Einstürz. Ich bin ja ein bisschen skeptisch immer, also alle freuen sich immer über die Simpsons, wenn die mir wieder was vorhergesehen haben und Trump Präsident und hast du nicht gesehen und alle rasten immer aus. Also Ich denke mir, wie viele Folgen haben die mittlerweile gemacht? So viele, wie es Tage auf der Welt gibt. Ja, ich meine, was wir alles für Nachrichten kriegen, oh, was habt ihr vorhergesehen in unserem Podcast? Ich meine, wir haben jetzt 230 mal eine Stunde, kann sich jetzt jeder selber ausrechnen, wie viel Content das insgesamt ist, wie viele Worte wir da gesagt haben und wir gesagt haben, ha ha ha, wäre es nicht lustig, wenn Schmetterling Bürgermeister von Uelzen wird. Fünf Wochen später wurde tatsächlich der erste Schmetterling zum Bürgermeister von Uelzen gewählt. Und dann steht man natürlich wieder im Rampenlegi, woher konnte das wissen so. Aber nein, wir sagen einfach so viele Dinge. Und die fiese Motte, die es nicht geschafft hat, die Stadt verklagt uns. Ja, ich sage es voraus, die Motte wird nämlich in ein paar Jahren dann Bürgermeister. Und hinterlässt es wie bei König der Löwen so ein Brachland. Ja. Wo man schon sagt, also beim Schwerterling wird es gut, wählt halt nicht die Motte. Genau wie man bei König der Löwen denkt, ja, wählt halt nicht den mit dem vernarbten Auge. Also der einzig dunkle Löwe habe ich auch noch nie im Echt gesehen, im Echt geleben. Ja, der irgendwo in der Höhle, in den Bergen wohnt, wo ein riesiger Lava-Fluss draus kommt, wählt den halt einfach nicht. Wählt den halt einfach mal nicht. Der hängt mit Hyänen ab, der halt sagt auch, dass er das Land für sich will und seine Diktatur aufrechterhalten. Sein Parteiprogramm besteht darin, die Menschheit zu versklaven. Ich meine, klar, ein Parteiprogramm ist immer eines, was dann tatsächlich umgesetzt wird, ist immer was anderes, wissen wir alle. Aber trotzdem. Ganz ehrlich, so ein paar catchy Sprüche und so, die locken einen natürlich auch dann irgendwie schon ein bisschen an. Ja, Blut, Mord, Tod, ich bring euch alle um. Klar, das klingt schmissig. Klingt erstmal schmissig, aber lest mal zwischen den Zeilen. Ja, guck mal, was wirklich dahinter steckt, welche menschenverachtenden Ideologien. Ich will nur sagen, man hätte darauf kommen können. Also so bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ja, sorry. Das war dumm. Den Fehler machen wir nicht nochmal. Den Fehler machen wir nicht nochmal. Aber du meinst, es war so eine Protestwahl, dass eigentlich niemand den Schmetterling wollte, aber der halt Wahlkampf gemacht hat mit, wollt ihr wirklich eine Motte? Nein, also wählt mich. So ein bisschen. Am Ende waren alle unzufrieden, aber zumindest keine Motte. Ich glaube, sie haben auch so, wie jetzt dann die ganzen, unsere Großeltergeneration quasi immer baut, wir wussten nicht, was da passiert, wir wussten nicht, was da vor sich geht, wer hätte das ahnen sollen, dass es das auch im König der Löwen-Universum gibt, dass dann die Gazelle wirklich sagt, wir wussten nicht, was passiert. Ja, wir haben damals möglichst viele Hasen im Dachboden versteckt. Wir konnten ja nicht wissen, was passiert am Ende, dass Hyänen kommen. Ich meine, Hyänen sind erstmal nette Tiere. Man will da jetzt nicht von vor... Also klar, man hört ja vieles, aber man will ja dann nicht von Anfang an dagegen sein. Die haben auch Möglichkeiten geschaffen. Also ich sag mal, gab es irgendwie Freizeitangebote und so von den Hyänen, Veranstalten und so. Die Uniformen waren schmissig, das Fell war schmissig. Das Fell sah richtig schick aus. Also es waren stramme Jungs. Nee, kann auch sein. Ich glaube auch, dass das in den Bildungsplan sehr eingeflossen ist, dass so junge Löwen und junge Gazellen das auch wirklich lernen. Dass es nicht nochmal passiert. Dass es auf gar keinen Fall nochmal passiert, ja. Nee, ich glaube, das ist auch vorbei. Jetzt sind wir eh schon im Politischen, jetzt sind wir eh schon knietief ins Wasser der Politik gewartet. Lass uns doch mal noch ein Köpper weitergehen und richtig tief eintauchen, denn ja, es ist passiert, US-Wahl hat stattgefunden. Ja, vor acht Wochen, was ist das hier, Late to the Party, was ist das für eine Rubrik jetzt? Naja, ist es die Too Soon Show? Ist es Too Soon? Nein, Too Late.
Die Too Late Show.
Und ja, du hattest mich ja dankenswerter eingeladen.
Wir wollten eine schöne Wahlparty machen. Schön die Wahlparty verfolgen, da wurde tatsächlich die Aufnahme gesperrt, gestört, als seine Horde Freunde reinkamen, irgendwie mit schönen Robbie Bobble in der Hand und dann so Brillen mit so 20-20 Brillen auf der Nase. So, ey Stefan, kommst du später noch rüber, wir machen Party zur Wahl. Und ich wurde dankenswerter Alter auch eingeladen. Das heißt, wir hatten mal wirklich einen ungezwungenen, nahezu freundschaftlichen Abend gemeinsam, oder? Ja, na ja, also irgendwann dann so gegen zehn, korrigier mich, wenn ich da falsch liege, habe ich dann gedacht, das dauert mir jetzt dann doch auch irgendwie ein bisschen zu lang. Nachdem ich dir gesagt habe, du, das dauert doch ewig, bis dein Gewinner feststeht. Und ich gesagt habe, nee, komm mal, so um ein, zwei Uhr ist das durch. Ich habe abgesagt. Ich habe abgesagt. Ich habe zu spät abgesagt, aber und jetzt fällt dir vielleicht auf die Füsse, dass wir schon so viel Zeit miteinander verbracht haben und Simpsons-like wahnsinnig viele Wörter rausgebracht haben aus unserem Mundloch, nämlich hast du gesagt, Zitat Florentin will, ich liebe es, wenn Leute absagen. Ja, und ich dachte mir, ja, und ich liebe es auch und du wahrscheinlich auch, dann es übers Herz zu bringen, abzusagen und einen Plan zu canceln. Vor allem, wenn du eine Party absagst, du hast ja noch vier Eimer Chicken Nuggets, drei Eimer Chicken Wings, die Chili Wings, die hast du dann alle für dich. Du hast ja immer noch diese Uelzen-Snack-Variationen mit den Pommels, mit den Steaks, mit den Chips, die hast du ja trotzdem noch. Richtig, die sind ja schon offen. Und die sind auch erstmal nicht weg, also die sind dann erstmal da. Die sind halt anwesend. Du weißt, für den nächsten Monat habe ich hier eine Snack-Variation. Monat oder einen Abend, Stefan. Wurde der zugelangt, wurde der richtig zugelangt in die Gummiewürmer, die sauberen Gummiewürmer? Ich habe tatsächlich schon ein bisschen was bestellt, das kam dann alles noch an, von Pizza Hut kam dann die Cheesy Bites Pizza, bin nicht ganz ehrlich, da kamen dann ein paar Cheesy Bites zu viel und Chicken Finger und die waren dann halt erstmal da und die mit den USA-Fähnchen und so und die Deko war bestellt, die 2020 Brillen waren aufgesetzt und was für tolle Brillen sind das, denn zum ersten Mal kann man wieder durchgucken. Herrlich. Also seit 2000, kann man wieder... Quäle zehn Jahre, seit 2010 warten wir drauf, dass wir wieder gucken können. Die zehn blinden Jahre, wie sie vielleicht auch in die Geschichtsschreibung eingehen werden, wo wir alle durch irgendeine fünf schauen mussten. Genau. War furchtbar. Einisschen ärgerlich, dass dieses Jahr Silvester quasi abgesagt wird,
man aber durch die Silvesterbrillen endlich mal wieder hätte was sehen können.
Ja, das wird noch ein ganz trauriges Kapitel.
Wir werden natürlich eine schöne Silvestergala machen,
dass falls ihr denkt, oh, was mache ich an Silvester,
könnt ihr die Silvester, die Podcast-Uvo-Silvestergala hören.
Genau, die Live-Show.
Ja, schon ein bisschen tragisch.
Aber wie ist eigentlich momentan der Status, interessiert mich, du hast ja anscheinend einen Weitblick zum Thema Pizzarand bei Pizza Hut. Ich, mein Weitblick in der Hinsicht ist, nee, Tunnelblick habe ich auch. Ich habe Tunnelblick auf maximal viel Käse gerichtet. Aber also... Jetzt ist ein Käserand, der ist mir zu knusprig. Ja, lass uns noch mal kurz die Historie durchgehen. Angefangen hat es mit Pizza, mit Rand, Rand war die grosse Enttäuschung.
Ich glaube, Rand ist schon mal ein Unfall. Ich glaube, man wollte kein Rand. Ich glaube, der Rand ist ein Beiwerk.
Ja, notwendigerweise ein Rand. Du hast ja zumindest, ich meine, die Pizza ist ja dahingehend schon klug, dass sie gesagt hat, lass uns den Kreis nehmen mit dem kleinstmöglichen Umkreis pro Fläche, haben sie ja schon den Kreis gewählt.
Also eigentlich könnte man sich ja bei der Quadratpizza mal beschweren, dass die ja mehr Rand hat. Aber dann kam ja Phase zwei, Käse im Rand. Was sich auch in Amerika... Ist Käse auf dem Rand, nicht Phase zwei und Käse im Rand? Richtig. Das ist nicht überbackenen Rand. Ja, Phase drei ist dann Käse sowohl im Rand als auch auf dem Rand. Genau. Dann gab es den Pizzarand, wo auf dem Rand nochmal Tomatenmark und Belag war, wo die Grenze schon ein bisschen verschwommen ist. Ja, wo die ersten Kritiker dann auch laut wurden und die ersten Gegenparteien, wo man dann gesagt hat, nee, jetzt hat sich die Pizza in eine falsche Richtung entwickelt. Lass uns alle wieder einen Vogelblick aufsetzen, mal einen Schritt zurückgehen, das Bild von weiter weg betrachten und sagen, das ist jetzt einfach nur noch lächerlich. Ja, weil die Leute gesagt haben, ich kann das ja da nicht greifen, weil sonst dapst ich ja da in die Soße rein und haben die gesagt, gut, dann machen wir darum nochmal einen Teigrand. Wir alle erinnern uns an die Protestmärsche. Ränder haben auch Vorteile, Ränder haben auch Stop, the Count. Da machen wir halt einen Rand mit Käse und Tomate, aber darum nochmal einen separaten Rand.
Und dann wurden die Pizzen immer größer.
Dann gab es natürlich zum großen Pizza-Excess 1944.
Die Pizza-Inflation.
Pizza-Inflation.
Wo Pizzen zu groß waren.
Ja.
Wo man gesagt hat, das muss enden.
Nimm zwei, bestell zwei.
Und dann gab es ja noch die Tendenz, dass man sagt, warum nicht den Rand nach innen verlegen.
Genau.
Also sozusagen wie so ein Teller-Ballanceur. Wie sagt man, nicht Plattenspieler, nee, der halt den Tellerdreher. Ja, Balancierer vielleicht. Der Balancierer, dass man sagt, du Trottel, greif doch die Pizza nicht von außen, sondern greif die doch von innen. Dann hattest du innen den Rand, Randinnen
Mittelpunkt der Pizza und konntest
das dann sozusagen wie so eine Eistüte
in der Mitte nehmen und dann
musstest du halt schnell rotieren lassen auf
deinem Finger, das ist klar. Und dann gibt es
ja auch die Calzone, quasi nur Rand,
also Rand,
wo man einfach gesagt hat, man stülpt die
Pizza einmal um. Ja, eine Pizza, ne, die Calzone
ist ja eine dreidimensionale Pizza eigentlich. Das Idee der Pizza eine Dimension höher gelegt. Was unser Universum ist, stellt sich letztlich als Calzone förmlich heraus. Ja, ganz kritisch wird es natürlich, wenn wir die vierdimensionale Pizza erreicht haben. Dann wird es richtig kritisch. Dann haben wir ein echtes Problem. Und dann hast du ja erst mal gesagt, okay, nee, Rand wieder nach außen. Und dann, was ich aber auch in Amerika gesehen habe, war Hotdog im Rand. Oh ja. Also Würstchen im Rand. Also ehrlich gesagt, jetzt bei der Wahlnacht wollte ich auch die Hotdog-Randpizza bestellen. Die war aber, glaube ich, für den, jetzt frag ich mich nicht warum, Mulan-Film. Gebrandet einfach wirklich, ja. Gebrandete Kurzzeitaktionenion, hatte ich vor ein paar Monaten mal irgendwann gegessen in Berlin.
Stimmt, bei der Berlinale, als ich bei der Berlinale war und alle abends gut essen ging und ich ging und ich war dann bei Pizza hatten mit dem Kumpel und habe dann da diese Hotdog-Pizza gegessen aus dem Mulan-Film, ich weiß, Lilo und Stitch, irgendwie sowas, wo ich dachte, wo habt ihr hier, ich verstehe schon den Gedanken, man will halt ab und zu diese Hotdog-Pizza machen, man braucht irgendwie einen Aufhänger, weil es auch ein bisschen zu disgusting ist und diese ganzen Gruppen davor mit, wir wollen keinen Hotdog, man kennt es. Und deswegen glaube ich, bringen die das, docken die jetzt mal so einen Film an und suchen sich irgendeinen Grund aus, oh, bei Minute drei, zwölf fällt mal der Begriff
Hotdog, komm, baller die Hotdog-Pizza
wieder raus. Ist natürlich auch schwierig, wenn du dann
so drei Produkte hast und drei Franchises
und die dann aufteilen musst und sagst, ja klar,
Shrek ist der Waldmeister Slushie.
Der ist grün, Shrek
easy, kein Problem.
Mulan,
vielleicht was so asiatische
Soße. Ja, also so Frühlingsrollen, asiatisch irgendwas so. Guck mal mal. Lilo und Stitch. Boah, die sind in Hawaii unterwegs. Ja. Was mit Ananas? Ja, so eine Pizza hat. Ja, es passt lächerlich gut. Es passt viel zu gut. Es war viel zu gut für diesen Gag. Die beiden sitzen da und da, fuck, wir sind nur ein Gag aus dem Podcast-Ufo, aber das funktioniert hier gar nicht. Was passiert mit uns, wenn die merken, dass der Gag nicht aufgeht? Was geschieht? Moment mal, nein, Rudi, die Schäle! Nein! Ja, es hat nicht funktioniert. Aber es stimmt schon, es ist schwierig. Aber vielleicht, es gibt ja auch oft so, dass Sachen aus Filmen rausgeschnitten werden. Vielleicht gab es irgendwie eine riesige Schaschlik-Szene bei Mulan oder so oder eine grosse Hotdog-Szene, wo die so versuchen müssen, einen Hotdog-Eating-Contest oder so.
Aber auch die Vorstellung finde ich gut, dass sie die Schaschlik-Szene rausschneiden mussten.
Der Pizza hat gesagt, jetzt haben wir diese Hotdog-Pizza vorbereitet, jetzt macht ihr da nicht eine Schaschlik-Szene rein.
Jedenfalls habe ich jetzt die Cheesy-Bite-Rand-Pizza gehabt,
was im Prinzip eine normale Pizza
ist, aber du kannst nicht jede nehmen. Du kannst nur
die Top-5 nehmen.
Die stärksten Pizzen. Salami,
Prosciutto, Margarete,
da, Margarita.
Margarete,
Margarete.
Es ist nur was für die stärksten Pizzen.
Das muss man sich erarbeiten als Pizza.
Richtig. Und die verbraten die nicht.
Die machen ja keine, das ist so ein No-Bull-Tit, keine Experimente-Pizza. Top Five, grossen fünf. Und dann hast du draußen Cheesy Bites, was im Prinzip sind gefüllte Pizzabrötchen mit Käse. Oder anders ausgedrückt ein Rand mit Käsefüllung, zerstückelt und um 90 Grad Genpizza gedreht. Käsebrötchen. Ist im Grunde ein Käsebrötchen, aber es klingt halt cooler, wenn es Jimmy beizutzt wird. Nicht überbacken, aber deswegen würde ich davon abraten, weil der Begriff, der wird nur Unruhe stiften. Aber jetzt mal eine Idee. Nach Cars, nach Birds, nach Cats, nach Dogs. Pizzas. Pizzas. Eine kleine Margarita-Pizza sagt, ich will auch mal eine von den ... Also, ich will Quadroformaggi werden. Ich will eine Quadroformaggi werden. Aber die Mutter sagt... Und Antonio, der Vater... Antonio sagt, na, bist du dumme, du kannst doch kein Quadroformaggi werden, du bist eine Margarita. Meine Schatze, jetzt lass den Kleinen, lass den Kleinen ein bisschen... Und dann gibt es halt so eine Story von wegen. Der nette Pizzajunge. Der einzige ist,
der die Pizzen versteht, was sie
reden. Der die ausliefert. Genau,
der Domino-Pizzajunge, der aber
eigentlich Pizzabäcker sein will.
Aber das erfährt man
nicht. Das ist nur für uns.
Ach so, sorry.
Dafür steht das im Abspann dann noch.
Das steht im Abspann erklärt.
Bei den Texttafeln am Ende.
Der wollte, haben wir nicht mehr im Film unterbekommen.
Hat nicht mehr gepasst und fand mir nicht so wichtig.
Naja.
Der fährt bei Dominos, weil er Geld braucht.
Aber eigentlich will er Pizzabäcker werden,
der traditionelle Pizzeria seines Vaters.
Der leugnet aber seine Existenz.
Der Vater leugnet die Existenz des Pizzaboten.
Des Jungen.
Warum?
Seines Sohnes.
Weil es vielleicht so ein Player ist oder so. Das können wir dann herausfinden. Wir sind noch nicht im Film. Wir müssen die Fragen noch nicht beantworten. Wir drehen noch nicht morgen. Wir sind in der Buchversion. Wir sind noch in der Development-Fahrze. Also, ich finde es nur schön. Ich meine nur, weil... Ja, weil du kannst ja, wenn du sagst, es kann eine Margarita-Pizza eineroformaggi werden. Jetzt sagst du, ja, klar. Aber in dem Film müsste man eher so eine Moral machen wie, auch eine Margarita ist auch gut. Also es kommt darauf an, was du draus machst. Ja, weil alle Filme haben diese Moral. So selbst als, ich weiß nicht, was die Moral von Cars ist. Ich glaube, dass ein Twingo auch ein Auto ist. So was wird schon irgendwie die Moral sein. Irgendwo in Cars 4 oder so wird das schon mal untergebracht werden. Ich habe nicht die Lust, dass unser Pizza-Film nicht herbeschlägt. Vielleicht ist unsere Botschaft einfach, Margareta kann auch greif nach den Sternen, greif nach der Ananas, greif nach vier Käsesorten, greif nach vier verschiedene Oh, sie hat schon drei. Sie sammelt die. Genau. Jetzt haben wir es.
Jetzt sind wir in so einem Avengers.
Spielberg.
Avengers Endgame-artigen.
Jetzt haben die den McGuffin.
Wir haben so einen McGuffin verstreut.
Die muss nämlich die vier Käsesorten auf der Welt finden.
Ja, genau.
Und zwar macht sie das mit dem kleinen Pizza-Jungen Federico.
Auf dem Dominos-Roller, den er geklaut hat, weil er da gar nicht mehr arbeiten will, hat er den Dominos-Roller geklaut.
Und dann zusammen mit dem 16-jährigen Federico, Federico González, bis in Side Story, der ist eigentlich kein Italiener, aber nicht nur Italiener, andere, whole different plot. Egal, egal, egal. Und er will nämlich Marcia beeindrucken, das Mädchen von dem an. Geniale Geschichte, finde ich gut. Die Moral ist dann natürlich schwierig, weil am Ende wird er gegessen
oder wird halt nicht gegessen.
Doch, wird er gegessen. Genau, die
Moral ist, mein ganzes
Leben wollte ich eine Quattro Famagy werden.
Wofür? Um es gegessen zu werden? Warum eigentlich?
Weil andere sagen,
eine Margarita ist nichts wert,
aber nur weil
das deren
Idealbild für mich, die letzten 20 Minuten bin auch nur ich, der erklärt, was die Moral Ich bin ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, ein, natürlich. Also, ihr erinnert euch doch noch an diese Figur hier. Können wir die kurz einnennen? Ja. Genau, die Figur von dem vierten Käse. Die war lustig, die fand ich lustig.
Kannst du ganz kurz vielleicht?
Ja, ich finde die mega. Weil die hat ja sowas
gesagt wie, ich weiß auch nicht den Text ganz
genau, aber die meinte ja sowas wie
willst du wirklich Quattro Famagi
werden oder willst du es nur
weil alle wollen, dass du Quattro Famagi
bist? So, und dann meinte ja
Piz,
der Pizzaboy, die Pizza, ne, die Pizza selber meinte. Meinte ja die Pizza selber, nee, nee, ich will unbedingt eine Quadroformatik werden, so. Hä, worauf wollte ich nicht aus? Also, am Ende und das Publikum die ersten stehen so, stehen so au, haben schon so die Jacke angezogen, und du rufst aber auch von der Leinwand runter, nee, bleibst du kurz den Sitzen. Jetzt muss ich nochmal, können wir nochmal ganz kurz reingucken? Wir hätten das schneiden können, wir hätten das alles schneiden. Nein, am Ende merkt er, dass er eigentlich als Margarita schon okay gewesen wäre und kratzt dann wieder die Fromaggi ab und gibt die dann den Enten und die tragen das auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Das Prosciutto e Fungi war invertiert, aber jetzt und dadurch wie invertiert? Die war invertiert, die reist in der Zeit zurück. Ach so. Die ist im blauen Team. Also, bist du jetzt eine Fungi e Prosciutto oder eine Prosciutto e Fungi? Nee, ich bin invertiert, ich bin eine Fungi e Prosciutto. Sagt die dann rückwärwärts reist in der zeit zurück wird ausgespuckt aus dem kunden und wird dann zu einem teigballen zurück gemacht aber es ist tatsächlich glaube ich es wäre Christopher Nolan sitzt im Publikum und sagt I don't get it und am Ende so Kreisblende auf Christopher Nolans Gesicht mit so einem Ja, okay. Aber ich glaube, es würde
ganz gut reinpassen, weil
ich weiß nicht, wenn man sich mal so alte Disney-Filme
anguckt, in meinen Augen ergibt die Hälfte
davon überhaupt gar keinen Sinn.
Top-3-Liste
an Disney-Filmen, die keinen Sinn ergeben.
Auf Platz Nummer 1, Die Schöne und
das Biest, ergibt schlicht
keinen Sinn, der Film. Wie?
Ich habe den letzten nochmal angeguckt, Disney Plus, habe ich mir jetzt geholt und habe mir einen Film angeguckt und er ergibt einfach keinen Sinn, weil die Aussage ist ja, der das Biest, der Fluch, also der Prinz wird in Biest verwandelt und der Fluch kann nur gebrochen werden, wenn ihn jemand liebt und man sich gegenseitig liebt. Also im Sinne von nicht weil er so schön ist, sondern wegen seinen inneren Werten. Dann kommt ja Protagonistin und verliebt sich in ihn und so weiter und so weiter. Und die haben so ein Timelimit eingebaut, damit der Film nicht sich verliert in Schneeballschlachten und irgendwie zeigt mir das Schloss und ja, weiter, weiter. Nee, es gibt ein Timelimit. Es gibt ein Timelimit. Wenn die Rose verwelkt ist, dann hat er keine Chance mehr den Fluch zu brechen. So, und dann verlieben die sich ineinander und alles ist perfekt, weil sie liebt ihn wegen seinen inneren Werten, er liebt sie, alles super. Und dann aber, oh nein, die Rose verwelkt schon, wo man sich ja fragt, ja was wäre denn so schlimm daran, wenn der Fluch nicht gebrochen wird, weil es ist doch alles ideal. Sie liebt ihn wegen seinen inneren Werten, er ist auch gut drauf, passt doch. Aber nein, der Fluch ist dann doch noch nicht ganz gebrochen, ein Rosenblatt ist noch da, er verwandelt sich in den Prinzen. Und sie liebt ihn immer noch. Und jetzt ist er hübsch und wobei er eigentlich ja eigentlich schon, aber es ergibt keinen Sinn, weil eigentlich die bessere, vor allem in dem Moment, ich habe den Film davor noch nicht gesehen, in dem Moment dachte ich mir, oh nein, der Fluch wird nicht gebrochen, was ist denn, wenn du immer so ein Biest sein musst?
Und eigentlich die richtige Antwort wäre, ja passt doch, ist doch alles cool, du liebst mich ja nicht, wie ich aussehe, sondern wegen meinen inneren Werten.
Das viel bessere Ende des Films wäre doch gewesen, dass sie sagen, ja scheisse auf den Fluch, wir leben einfach so weiter als die Schöne und das Biest.
Aber stattdessen wird es so als, oh nein, der Fluch wird nicht gebrochen, ganz merkwürdig. Du meinst eigentlich verunglimpft, dass eigentlich es halt am Ende doch die falsche Aussage, weil ja alle Charaktere bis zum Ende Hässlichkeit immer noch verurteilen. Ja, es ist eine Ultraschung. Allein die Prämisse ist super strange.
Ich zaubere jemanden hässlich,
so lange, bis ihn jemand wegen seinen...
Ich bin gezaubert, da brauchst du dich nicht auffordern.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ich zaubere jemanden hässlich und
erst wenn er wegen seinen inneren Werten
geliebt wird, wird er wieder schön.
Was dann aber ja nicht mehr nötig ist,
weil er ja geliebt wird wegen seinen inneren Werten.
Also das ist ja eine ganz merkwürdige Art von Belohnung. Maybe it's not what he wants, but more what he needs. Wie meinst du das jetzt? Was? Nee. Nee, was meinst du damit? Nee, meiner Meinung nach, wenn ich das sage, dann sagen alle, oh, ja. Stehen alle auf und applaudieren und du kannst dich verabschieden. Ja, in den seltensten Fällen eine Rückfrage. Jetzt wurde mich so drauf festnagelt. Weiß nicht. Es haben ja alle das bekommen, was sie wollten und auch das, was sie gebraucht haben. Warum können sie nicht einfach so weiterleben mit dem Fluch? Habe ich nicht einen Oscar für diesen Film bekommen? Ja, aber aber ist doch dann auch nicht totreden. Haben Sie schon mal einen Film gemacht? Nein. It's hard, man. Ja, wirklich? Nee, ich glaube, das stimmt schon, was du sagst. Es ist problematisch, dass bis zum Ende alle Figuren Hässlichkeit immer noch als etwas unumkehrbar Furchtbares.
Ja, es ist total
nicht akzeptieren, dass sie ja hässlich sein können,
wenn man geliebt wird. Vielleicht denkt er aber auch
in die Zukunft und denkt sich, sie
liebt mich jetzt so, was wenn sie mal irgendwann
mich nie mehr liebt, dann bin ich ja immer noch ein hässliches
Biest, dann habe ich die Figur, ist dann die Chance,
dass mich jemand findet.
Ich habe es nicht verstanden, ich dachte mir,
das ist kein gutes Ende, hätten doch irgendwie aber keine Ahnung, Zeitreisen noch sein können oder so, oder dass sie einfach sagen. Das ist doch auch mal cool. Du zeigst diesen Fluch und oh, so kann man den Fluch brechen, aber am Ende merken alle, eigentlich ist der Fluch gar nicht so schlimm. Mega Fluch. Passt schon. So, und die Hexe denkt sich, ja Leute, das ist ja auch scheiße jetzt, oder? Ich bin ein cooles Monster, Alter. Ja, eben. Vor allem Teile des Films drehen sich darum,
dass er sie nur retten kann, weil er
so ein großes Monster ist. Sie wird angegriffen von
Wölfen und er kämpft gegen die Wölfe
und kann sie beschützen, weil er so stark
ist als Monster.
Gibt es da auch in jedem
Moment im Disney-Film, Anfang
von Akt zwei,
wo er in den Sieg hochgeht,
die Geigen kommen und er sie befreien kann, er rennt
über die Wiese, ist ein ganz schnelles Monster.
Dieser eine Moment, wo man droht, vom Drachen zu fliegen oder hinfällt, weil man zu gross
ist, aber dann fängt man sich wieder.
Nee, ganz merkwürdiger Film, auch nicht gut gealtert irgendwie.
Ja, ist ja jetzt gut. Wie viele Sterne? Trotzdem acht von zehn Sternen. Ja, enttäuschende Zehn von zehn Sternen, aber muss auch nicht sein. Ich habe jetzt zum ersten Mal meinen allerersten und da habe ich vielleicht auch schon mal on air gelogen, bin ich ganz ehrlich, zum ersten Mal einen Studio Ghibli-Film geguckt. Ich habe zum ersten Mal Spirited Away geschaut. Wie heißt der auf Deutsch? Chihirus Reise ins Zauberland. Zauberland. Habe ich gesagt. Nicht Wunderland, sondern Zauberland. Ja, was hast du gesagt, sage ich sonst? Wenn ich sage Chihirus Reise ins Zauberland, was glaubst du, kommt dann für ein Wolf? Zauberwelt, aber Zauberland. Viele sagen Wunderland, wegen fabelhafte Welt der Amelie. Chihiros Reise in die fabelhafte Welt der Amelie. Fabelhafte Welt der Alice. Das ist ein Crossover, das so nicht hätte sein sollen. Den fand ich fantastisch. Toller Film? Da gefällt mir mehr. ich finde, der ist komplexer. Und jetzt bilde ich mir auch jetzt schon ein, dass alle Studio-Gibli-Filme vielleicht ein bisschen komplexer und ein bisschen nicht auf den grossen, auf die Effekthascherei, auf die grossen Momente, auf die grossen Elton-John-Nummern aus ist, sondern die Filme, da geht es um Liebe zum Detail, da geht es um Storytelling.
Ja.
Ne, doch, ehrlich gesagt, ich mag auch alle Disney-Filme. Ich mag auch die ganzen Disney-Pixar-Filme, mag ich auch alle.
Aber die ganzen Studie, die Ghibli-Filme könnt ihr jetzt auch, Prinzessin Mononoko und so, kann man jetzt alle auf Netflix gucken.
Cool.
Which is nice. Und die ganzen anderen Filme halt bei Disney Plus. Das heißt, eigentlich eine gute Zeit, um jetzt mal endlich alles aufzuholen. Ja, Prinzessin Mononoko habe ich meine Zeit lang jeden Sonntag angeschaut. Bestimmt so ein paar Monate lang habe ich jeden Sonntag, habe ich mir immer samstags schöne Fertiglasagne geholt, die habe ich mir dann Sonntag morgens in den Ofen geschoben. Warum ist es immer verbunden, in der Tradition ist immer mit Essen verbunden? Ja, aber Essen sind gut, weil Essen, da muss man immer warten. So, man kann das gut rummachen. Ich mag Essen, das lange braucht. Rituale magst du auch. Weil man hat so ein, ja, ich sage immer so ein goldenes Zeitfenster, wo man sagt, ja, ich muss jetzt warten, bis die Lasagne fertig ist. Ich kann jetzt nicht anfangen, meine Wand zu streichen. Und du hast die Zeit für dich. Das ist die schönste Zeit, in der du auf irgendwas wartest. Wusstest du schon beim ersten Mal, dass es wieder tun wirst? Ich weiß es nicht. Weil ich finde es sehr clever, weil wir normalen Menschen sind da anders als du. Wir finden etwas gut und dann haben wir das als gute Erinnerung abgespeichert und gucken den nächsten anderen Film. Du weißt, Lasagne war mega, war genau das Gute. Ich würde jetzt das nächste gute Restaurant suchen oder das nächste, keine Ahnung, das nächste Gericht, was mir gefällt.
So, dann der Film, das Monolog fandst du super. Ich würde jetzt sagen, ja gut, den kenne ich ja jetzt schon, will ich einen anderen Film. Nein, du hast gesagt, das hat mir gut gefallen, der Abend war perfekt, ich stelle den jetzt jeden Sonntag wieder her. Ja, es ist die goldene Kombo. Manchmal im Leben hast du ja einfach so gute Kombinationen, wo du weißt, das passt einfach gut zusammen. Und dann guckst du ja auch nicht weiter, wenn jetzt irgendwie so ein italienischer Pizzabacker, sagen wir jetzt zum Beispiel, der hat jetzt die genau richtigen vier Käsesorten und die passen genau zusammen, dann sagt er auch nicht, ja, jetzt lass uns noch mal den Gorgonzola probieren, jetzt lass uns noch mal den Pancetta probieren und so. Der sagt dann, nee, das ist es jetzt halt. Oder der sagt auch nicht, was ist mit Cinque Formaggi? Geh mal in ein italienisches Restaurant und sag Una Pizza Cinque Formaggi Perfavorre, wie die dich angucken. Ja, dann kriegst du eine Cinque ins Gesicht. Dann kriegst du die Pfeffermühle aber zwischen die Rippen gedrückt. Jesus. Nein, diese Szenen funktionieren nicht, wenn du über deinen eigenen Witz lachst. Du bist auf einem Schlittenberg, fährst du den Schlitten runter und der Schal flattert hinter dir her und du sagst Wow. aber du kannst nicht alleine in deinem Zimmer sitzen und sagen,
dann kriegt er den ins Gesicht getreten.
Wow!
Einen Witznagel funktioniert nicht.
Wenn das die Szene ist von einem kleinen Comedian,
Federico, der kleine
Pizzabäcker, der will auch den Comedian?
Nein, nein, nein, dieser Federico-Storyline
ist viel zu aufgeblasen, der will
gleichzeitig seine Tante will Comedian
werden, die Krebs aber. Seine Schwester will das Bernsteinzimmer finden, das sind viel zu viele Plot-Arcs. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,en, der will gleichzeitig, seine Tante will Comedian werden, seine Schwester will das Bernsteinzimmer finden, das sind viel zu viele Plot-Arcs, das kriegen wir nicht gelöst, das kriegen wir einfach nicht hin.
Montage?
Nein, das kriegen wir nicht in einem Film. Für einen Film ist es zu viel, viel zu viel.
Werbung.
Hallo Leute, Flo und ich, wir sind zwei Leute, die Laptops brauchen täglich, beruflich, privat. Werbung. Laptop, man überlegt sich, was soll ich mir holen. Aber beides bei mir zu Hause rumfliegen ist unnötig, denn man könnte es kombinieren. Demnach mit einem Detachable, nämlich einem Laptop, wo man die Tastatur einfach abmachen kann und den Monitor als Hudbit nutzen kann.
Und da haben wir ein ganz fantastisches Exemplar für euch gefunden, nämlich das Microsoft Surface Book 3.
Das ist der brandneue Surface von Microsoft und der macht richtig Spaß.
Einfach per Tastendruck kann man das Display abnehmen und das Ganze kombiniert Geschwindigkeit, Grafik, eine ganz beeindruckende Gaming-Performance dank einer Nvidia-Grafikkarte und die Vielseitigkeit eines Laptops und eines Tablets. Also vereint beide die Vorteile, sowohl von einem Laptop als auch einem Touchpad, erhältlich in den Größen 13,5 Zoll oder 15 Zoll, wenn es ein bisschen grösser sein darf. Und falls ihr jetzt fragt, ja wo kriege ich das jetzt, wo soll ich mir das schnappen?
Cyberport, Cyberport! Bei unseren guten alten Freunden von Cyberport natürlich, die kennt ihr mittlerweile.
Das ist eure Anlaufstelle, wenn es um kompetente Beratung und Leistungen zum Thema Technik geht, da könnt ihr immer gerne vorbeigucken und euch ein neues Detachable holen.
Genau, deswegen geht einfach mal auf cyberport.de slash microsoft minus surface. Viel Spaß! Werbung Was war der längste Film, den du jemals geguckt hast? Herr der Ringe wahrscheinlich? Die sind schon echt lang. Die sind wahnsinnig lang. Die sind super lang. Immer wenn ich von einem Herr der Ringe Abend höre, so einem Herr der Ringe Marathon, ist immer, alle freuen sich mega drauf und sagen, ja, wir gucken alle in der Extended-Version und die Erzählung ist danach immer, ja, wir haben den ersten in der Extended geguckt und danach haben wir beide nur noch in den Neue geguckt und beim dritten sind wir reingefandt, eh schon. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ich habe ja auch mal alle Harry-Patter-Teile am Stück angeguckt, da habe ich jetzt auch einen, wo du echt ein tiefes Tal hast, weil die ersten vier sind gut und dann mit dem fünften habe ich komplett durchgeschlafen, dann habe ich die Story nicht mehr verstanden und dann war ich auch raus. Weil du die vergessen hast, weil du vorher diesen Zauber angewendet hast, wo du dann wie Hermine, den habe ich vergessen, Zauber. Ich habe vergessen, wie er heisst. Der Zauber ist so gut, dass niemand sich an ihn erinnern kann, vielleicht auch.
Vielleicht gibt es noch einen weiteren Harry-Potter-Teil, den niemand weiss, weil J.K. Rowling ihren Vergessenszauber angewendet hat. Obwohl, wenn J.K. Rowling Vergessenszauber hätte beherrschen würde, hätte sie ihn, glaube ich, schon angewendet, oder? Und zwar bei den, ich glaube auch, und zwar vor allem bei den Men in Black-Teilen, weil die ja die Idee erfunden haben mit Blitzdingsen. Ja.
Das heisst, wenn Ira funktionieren würde, hätte sie ihn auf uns angewandt, damit wir Men in Black vergessen, damit wir nicht sie outcornen können. Stimmt. Das hat aber Men in Black schon gemacht. Ja. Also haben wir damit bewiesen, Quad Era Demonstrandum, auch ein Zauber. Zeitreisen sind nicht möglich. Zeitreisen sind nicht möglich und es gibt keine Vergessenszauber in dieser Welt. Vielen, vielen Dank. Wir kommen voran. Was ist denn, dachte ich mir neulich, wenn du irgendwann mal merkst, du angenommen, irgendwann werden Zeitreisen erfunden, also lose. Erstmal so, man hört Word goes around, dass da bald was möglich ist. Und du merkst, du bist Stauffenberg. Du bist derjenige, der Erste, der zurückgereist ist, um Hitler umzubringen. Was heißt, du merkst das? Du merkst, dass du die Person bist, die wir historisch als Stauffenberg... Also du blätterst so das Geschichtsbuch und es gab keinen Attentat. Doch, es gab keinen Attentat. Ach so, ja, okay. Ich habe jetzt die Harry Potter-Zeitreisetechnologie erzählweise angewandt, wo es ein geschlossener Loop ist. Ja, aber wenn es das ja schon gab, dann muss ich es ja nicht nochmal machen. Doch, doch, doch, du musst es machen, du wirst es auch machen. Aber es ist ja schon passiert. Ja, aber es wird auch passieren, so ein geschlossossener Kreis. Du bist derjenige, der zu greif ist. Aber dann muss ich ja gar keine Entscheidung treffen. Der freie Wille ist auch bei Tenet, der komplett aussen vor. Oder wenn ich es nicht mache, wäre es nicht passiert worden. Wäre es nicht passiert, wäre alles andere auch nicht so passiert worden. Heißt, du musst das also machen. Ich meine, die Geschichte ist dahingehend ein bisschen langweilig, weil es Antat missglückt ist, wie du vielleicht weisst. Das heisst, es steht nicht so viel auf dem Spiel. Was denn, wenn es klappt, aber das macht eine neue Zeitachse auf und die lebst dann weiter und die ist erst Ende des Films. Oder du musst es verhindern, dass es klappt. Aber du weißt nicht warum. Ja, ja. Ja, ist ein interessantes... Nee, ich wollte nur mal... Nee, weil... Ist ein Brainstorming, du musst es nicht immer... Nee, nee, nee, überhaupt nicht. Aber ja, es... Ja. Nee, ich wollte nur mal sagen. Ich wollte nur mal.... Ist das nicht eigentlich die ernüchterndste Erkenntnis, dass wenn wir alle vor der Zeitmaschine stehen und niemand fällt eine coole Sache ein, die man machen kann? So, oh, naja, das geht ja nicht, weil dann ist das wieder Zeitachse falsch. Oder wir gucken, dass Hitler doch, nee, scheiße. Zeitachse. Und irgendwann wird es einfach so eine Art Kühlschrank, weil man merkt so, man merkt so, ja die Zeitmaschine, da muss man sehr viel Kühlakus haben und so. Der Erste legt dann so, seit Monaten keine Idee, und jemand legt der Erste so eine alte Pizza so daneben, weil es kühlt und der Erste benutzt es irgendwie, um obendrauf was zu stellen. Ja, genau. Und dann wird jetzt so ein Möbel, als Möbelstück integriert und dann so,
hä, benutzt du gerade unsere
Zeitmaschine, damit du deinen weirden
Käse daneben legst, um zu kühlen?
Hä, die haben das doch seit Wochen nicht benutzt.
Ich dachte, da ist Platz. Ne,
hä, das ist eine Zeitmaschine. Nein, du hast gesagt,
ich soll den Käse nicht in der Küche liegen lassen,
weil der so stinkt, also hab ich ihn halt
da in die Maschine getan.
Und sind das vier Käse-Sagen? Naja, die passen gut zusammen. Das ist die beste Story, die euch eingefallen ist zum Thema Zeitreisen. Aber ja, es stimmt schon. Das ist wahrscheinlich dann so ein Ding, jetzt hast du dir das ganze Jahr zu Weihnachten die Zeitmaschine gewischt. Am Ende steht sie nur rum. Du hast sie kein einziges Mal benutzt, du hast kein einziges Mal Hitler verhindert, du hast Genghis Khan nicht verhindert, ja, mach ich morgen, ja, okay, ja, oder mach's aber auch morgen, ja, ich mach's gestern, okay, der Zeitreisehumor wieder, da haben wir drüber geredet. Wegen dir sind alle Dinosaurier umgekommen, also du hast keinen Menschen verhindert. Ach ja, schwierig. Aber zurück zur Wahl. Ja, weil das war schon der Abend. Ich bin dann auch froh gewesen, dass ich das abgesagt habe, die ganze Scheiße, die ganze Nummer. Ja, stell dir vor, wir hätten vier Tage lang bei dir rumsitzen müssen, bis tatsächlich ein Gewinnerverstand, hätten wir so viele Pizzarender
gegessen. War das geil, nach Hause zu kommen,
direkt CNN anzumachen, wobei ich
am Anfang nicht CNN geguckt. Ich habe irgendwann
durch die Tweets, die über die Wahlen
Nächte, Tage geschrieben wurden,
gemerkt, dass alle CNN gucken,
habe dann auch CNN angemacht. Ich habe vorher, weil ich dachte,
ich dachte nie, kein Amerikaner guckt CNN.
Ich dachte, das wäre so eine deutsche,
europäische
Version, auf Amerika zu schauen, ah, ist der einzige amerikanische Länder, den wir kennen. Ich dachte, das ist ja gar nicht so beliebt. Turns out ist doch sehr beliebt da. Ich habe mal NBC News geguckt, als einziger wohl bei YouTube und habe es dann wirklich tagelang verfolgt. Und es war wahnsinnig spannend und cool. Vor allem dann, als dann klar wurde, dass Trump nicht der nächste Präsident wieder wird. Bei mir war es so, ich dachte mir so, okay, ich will die Wahl nicht sehen, aber ich hatte irgendwie so eine Art historische Verpflichtung, mich irgendwie damit zu beschäftigen. Dann dachte ich mir, was könnte ich machen, was jetzt nicht direkt was mit der Wahl zu tun hat, aber irgendwie noch passt. Und da habe ich mir dieses Video angeguckt von einem Historiker, der bewertet, wie realistisch Präsidenten in Filmen dargestellt wurden. Der dann sich Lincoln anschaut oder so und dann sagt, ja so und so, das ist korrekt und das ist nicht korrekt. Das habe ich mir angeguckt und das war es dann für mich, wo ich dachte, jetzt habe ich meine Pflicht getan. Weil du kannst ja nicht so sagen, keine Ahnung, jetzt in dem Moment, in dem jemand gewählt wird, was hast du gemacht, ich habe eine Doku über Napoleon angeguckt, so, du warst wo ganz anders, man muss ja schon gucken, wo man, dass man so einigermaßen dabei ist. Du warst während Napoleon an die Macht kam, hast du eine Doku über Napoleon geguckt? Ja, während Hitler an die Macht kam, hast du eine Doku über Genghis Khan angeschaut, warum denn oder während, genau, während Napoleon, ja, schlussend, ja. Das ist eigentlich, man fragt sich, ist es immer so das, was gerade passiert ist, am uninteressantesten eigentlich, oder? Ja, ja, doch, das stimmt schon. Für mich aber nicht. In der Zeit fand ich es fantastisch. Habe wahnsinnig viel Spaß gemacht. Vor allem dann am Anfang wieder die ganzen ich konnte mal damals bei der Trump-Wahl habe ich alle Staaten gewusst. Man kann auch die USA-Karte zeigen und ich könnte den Damen des Staates sagen.
Mittlerweile alles wieder vergessen.
Alles vergessen.
Und jetzt könnte ich es wieder. Das ist schön.
Und dann haben die immer einen Staat thematisiert.
Ich habe den immer gegoogelt und habe ganz viel über diese Staaten gelernt.
Weil ich finde das fantastisch.
Manche Staaten machen mir extrem Angst, habe ich gelernt.
Louisiana und so, wo ein Two Detectives spielt, habe ich schon mal erzählt.
Aber so ein Staat, der macht mir unfassbar viel Angst.
Weil da diese weirden Bäume, diese Weiden, diese Trauerweiden hängen überall, an diesen Sumpflandschaften, an diese Plantagenhäuser, und diese sehr grüne, aber auch sehr trostlose, traurige Landschaft und dann diese furchtbare Vergangenheit mit den Plantagen. Also das ist alles grauenhaft. Dann gibt es wahnsinnig schöne Staaten, so Colorado, weiß ich jetzt, wo es liegt, weiß ich, was da die Hauptstadt ist und so. Das macht mir Spaß. Aber ich habe da gar keine Ahnung. Und da ist mir auch gefallen, dass jeder US-Bundesstaat, klingt wahnsinnig amerikanisch. Ja. Und da denke ich mir, jedes Land macht mal so eine Ausnahme. Jedes Land, in jedem Land gibt es so eine Stadt, wo du denkst, naja.
Aber in den USA, jeder Staat klingt unglaublich amerikanisch. Okay, welche deutsche Stadt klingt am wenigsten deutsch?
Bei welcher Stadt könnte man sagen, wo ein Ausländer sagt, das liegt in Deutschland.
Ich dachte, vom Namen her, das klingt ganz woanders. Fiersen. Fiersen? Fiersen? Fiersen. Okay. Gut. Vielleicht müssen wir tatsächlich nach, wenn wir endlich, nicht endlich, aber wenn wir irgendwann mit Antenne Afrika fertig sind. Hä? Was ist das für ein widerfreudischer Versprecher? Was sind wir endlich mit Afrika? Wenn wir irgendwann alle Länder Afrikas besprochen haben, können wir Antenne Amerika machen. Antenne Arkansas, wo man nicht genau weiß. Alle Städte in Arkansas machen. Antenne Amerika, dann können wir alle Bundesstaaten Amerikas mal durchgehen. Warum nicht? Irgendwann hat die ganze Welt durch. Da weiss man viel zu wenig drüber. Ja, vor allem diese ganzen Quadrat-Bundesstaaten, wo man sich auch fragt, was soll das denn? Colorado ist, glaube ich, einfach ein Quadrat. Also ein Recht der Kalt. Mega. Auf wo gar keine Mühe wurde sich mehr gegeben. Aber manche Staaten sind so halb-halb. Halb irgendwelche weirden Grenzen und halb so krasse Striche.
Ja, ist auch schwierig.
Und dann ecken die immer an, so wie du dann alle Nachbarstaaten hast.
Schwierig, aber ich kann noch nicht mal alle deutschen Bundesländer.
Also ich bin da wirklich komplett verloren.
Ich wurde letztens gezwungen, bei Geogaster mitzuspielen,
so dieses Spiel, wo du irgendwo Google Maps irgendwo bist
und dann auf der Map klicken musst, wo du bist. Keine Chance, null. Meine Orientierung ist wirklich furchtbar. Ich war mal in Köln unterwegs und bin irgendwo, bin falsche U-Bahn gestiegen und bin dann irgendwo ausgestiegen und dachte mir, ach, dann laufe ich halt von hier aus, da kein Problem, lerne ich mal so ein bisschen die Umwelt kennen, kann ein bisschen Podcast hören, ein Lauf irgendwie dauert jetzt keine Ahnung, eine halbe Stunde oder so. Stell dich raus, war in Berlin. Bin gelaufen, bin gelaufen, bin gelaufen und bin irgendwann wieder an der Haltestation angekommen, wo ich angefangen habe. Ich habe es geschafft, wirklich einmal im Kreis zu laufen, wo ich mir dachte so, ach, was ist das denn für eine Haltestelle? Barbarossaplatz? What? Da habe ich da angefangen? Und da dachte ich mir wirklich so, vergiss es einfach, du bist einfach, also ich hatte wirklich diesen Moment, dass, wow, bin ich dumm. Also ich hatte eine Anerkennung für die Intensität meiner eigenen Dummheit. Wo du wirklich so sagst, das ist schon auch eine Leistung. Das ist wirklich eine Leistung, what the fuck? Also das ist schon wirklich auch eine Leistung, wo ich mir dachte, das kann da jetzt nicht sein. In New York gehst du ja regelmäßig verloren, als wir noch schön regelmäßig in New York waren, als es noch ging. Da warst du immer weg kurz. Und auch mindestens einmal pro Trip hast du mir geschrieben, ich weiß keine Ahnung, wo ich bin. Ich komme nicht zu dem Musical, wo wir jetzt 8000 Dollar ausgegeben haben. Sorry, ich weiß nicht, wo ich bin. Und ich brauche wahrscheinlich acht Stunden, um wieder in die Nähe zu kommen, wo wir mal angefangen haben. Also das ist schon regelmäßig. Man hat immer die Illusion, dass es so leicht ist mit diesen Avenues und so, dass man das so dieses Schachbrettmuster hat. Aber ich unterschätze halt dann auch immer die Dimensionen und denke mir dann halt, ja, das ist jetzt wie viele Kästchen. Weil du auch so bei diesen ganzen Apps immer nie weißt, wie die Dimensionen sind, das sieht immer so aus auf der Map, als wäre das irgendwie direkt nebenan, aber dann sind es halt ja schon mal 50 Meter oder Kilometer, ich weiß auch nicht, keine Ahnung, 50 Meter ist nicht so viel. Ja, 50 Meter, ich habe immer so, ich bin so, ich habe so ganz kruse, krude Referenzen, dass sich mir jemand sagt, also ich rechne das immer im Kopf noch um, ich rechne immer noch auf Mark um, wenn es um Distanzen geht, habe ich
immer noch, wenn jemand sagt so, boah, der hat den Ball 500 Meter weit geworfen, dann
denke ich immer, okay, 10 Meter Turm, stell es dir vor, 10 Meter Turm im Schwimmbad, ah,
so hoch, und jetzt leg den mal einmal so auf.
Und das Thema ist schon ganz so anders, wir sprechen ganz anders.
Wow, so weit? Oder alternativ einfügen, oh, das ist aber nicht so weit. Dann legt den Turm zur Seite, aha, und dann zweimal, dreimal, viermal, fünfmal, bis fünfzigmal, bis ich ungefähr dabei bin, wo fünfvold Meter sind. Und wie schon, ich stehe alleine, es ist Nacht mittlerweile, ich stehe alleine auf dem Schulhof, grillen, zirpen und die anderen sind schon nach Hause und ich sage, krass, crazy, der kann man weit werfen. Aber das ist zu weit, oder? Was mir gefehlt hat, ist die Fussballspielvergangenheit. Viele Kinder, Mädchen, Jungs haben halt so eine, haben mal Fussball gespielt und kennen oder sind mal auf dem Fussballplatz gelaufen in der Schule. Das heißt, da weiss man ungefähr, wie viele hundert Meter sind, nämlich die breite Seite eines Fussballfeldes. Und wenn man das einmal mal lang gelaufen ist, mal gecheckt hat, also. Ja, das ist ja auch manchmal willkürlich. Ich glaube, es gibt zum Beispiel jeder Mensch. Du bist Distanz relativ, glaubst du. Ich glaube, die Distanz ist relativ. Und ich glaube aber auch, weil jeder hat ja das einmal, einmal eins, einmal, einmal eins gelernt. Und also von eins bis zehn. Aber jeder hat eine, die er besonders gut kann. Lass mal mal fünf und zehn raus. Eins, fünf, zehn, eins, zwei, fünf, zehn, raus. Easy. Aber jeder hat eine, die er besonders gut kann, weil er sich da in der Schule mal eine Woche lang die beste Eselsbrücke oder sich halt mal eine Woche richtig reingehängt hat. Weil man hat ja nicht über seine gesamte Schulaufbahn dieselbe Aufmerksamkeit. Ich habe mich heute so gefreut, ich musste heute den Capture machen. Ich musste den Passwort zurücksetzen und das Capture war, lösen Sie folgende Matheaufgabe. Wie es halt so maximal einfach, damit man schnell machen kann,
aber könnte ein Computer jetzt nicht unbedingt machen, weil es ja geschrieben ist.
Ja, weil Computer vier mal acht nicht hinkriegt.
Ja, genau, da habe ich auch gedacht, aber es hat in Textform geschrieben und wahrscheinlich,
Computer können auch wahrscheinlich auf, ich bin kein Roboter klicken, weiß ich nicht.
Jedenfalls stand da, was ist sieben mal acht?
Und ich musste grinsen, weil das war die, die am schlechtesten konnte. Ja, weil sie am weitesten von fünf und von zehn entfernt sind. Das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen, ein bisschen ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen mag das gern. Es ist befriedigend. Sieben mal acht ist sechsundfünfzig. Es ist befriedigend zu sagen, der Rhythmus ist schön. Es ist eine schöne Form, sechsundfünfzig mag ich irgendwie. Sechsundfünfzig, fünf sechs ist ja wie so eine Strasse. Sieben acht, fünf sechs, sieben acht, weißt du, was da so alles drin vorkommt. So kann man es sich merken. Ist es bei jeder Multiplikation so, dass es eine Strasse gibt? Also drei mal zwei ist fünfundvierzig? Ja, geht doch. Drei mal zwei ist fünfundvierzig, zwei, drei, vier, fünf. Aber das fand ich schön. Was war deine Mathe gelöst? Sechs mal sechs ist sechsunddreißig, fand ich toll. Sechs mal sechs ist sechsunddreißig. Achtung, vier mal vier ist sechzehn. Ja. Oh, herrlich. Es gibt so eine sehr befriedigende Aufgabe. Die neuner Reihe fand ich ganz toll. Ja, weiß ich nicht. Drei mal drei ist neun, finde ich noch richtig gut, weil das so diese Ritterport, so 4 mal 4, das ist so die Quadratdinger, finde ich gut. Ich kann 7 besonders gut. Da habe ich mich mal richtig reingehängt als Kind. 36, 9, ja. Yes, das hänge ich mich rein, so 28, 21, hänge ich mich rein, 8 ist mir nicht ganz kritisch. Aber ich glaube, jeder Mensch, ich glaube, man kann Menschen daran erkennen, welche Zahl sie am besten multiplizieren können. Jeder hat eine. Manche können
die Sechser besonders gut, manche die Achter.
Die Sechser mag ich sehr gerne.
Die sechs mal sieben finde ich schön.
Die 42? Toll. Ist für dich, was ist deine
Lieblingszahlen eine sinnvolle Frage oder
albern?
Albern. Ne, ich finde, das ist eine sinnvolle Frage.
Ich bin auch ein Zahlenmensch. Ich mag Zahlen.
Ich kann mir Zahlen merken, ich kann mir Handynummer gut merken.
Ich kenne sehr viele Handynummern auswendig. Ich kenne von verstorbenen Personen Handynummern auswendig und ich bin da einfach ein Freak. Ich bin ein Freak für Zahlen, ich liebe Zahlen. Da könnte das Blitzlings wieder aktiv werden, dass du Wissen, das du hast. Das ist ja auch hast jetzt, du bist ja dein Gehirn sozusagen.
Bist du dein Gehirn oder hast du ein Gehirn?
Egal.
Oh, gute Frage. Ich bin meine Erinnerung, glaube ich.
Du hast ja deine...
Sind wir mehr unsere Erinnerungen und unsere Fertigkeiten?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Ach so.
Ich wollte eigentlich nur eine eigene Pizza zu mitnehmen.
Ich glaube, so ein Podcast, wie wir den machen, würde nicht funktionieren, wenn einer immer zu logisch antworten würde.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen weit hergeholt. Na da müsste man jetzt ein bisschen ausholen. Also ich würde eher sagen, also ist schon komisch, dass du Dinge nicht aktiv vergessen kannst, dass du nicht sagen kannst, die Nummer brauche ich nicht mehr, Delete. Also was hält dich davon ab, das zu vergessen? Dein Gehirn sagt, nein, ich halte an dieser Handy Nummer fest. Man kann es löschen. Ich glaube, ich kann genauso gut wie auf meinem Handy Dinge löschen. Du kannst nicht Gedanken löschen. Doch, aber die sind dann im Papierkorb. Ach, und den kriege ich nicht gelöscht. Aber den kriege ich auch auf allen anderen Devices nicht gelöscht. Also deswegen glaube ich, ist es so eine Art User Error. Ich glaube, wir sind alle nur zu doof. Ich glaube, es geht. Bestimmt können das Leute. Bestimmt können das Leute. Was ich mir letztens gefragt habe, wenn du eine externe Festplatte an deinem Laptop anschließt. So, jetzt kommt eine IT-Frage. Da habe ich mich schon aufgewollt. Wir können den Podcast kurz pausieren, ich habe echt eine Frage. Okay, jetzt kurz nicht der Podcast. Also ganz kurz, stopp. Also externe Festplatte an deinem Laptop. Jetzt hast du Dateien auf der externen Festplatte, Die ziehst du in den Papierkorb. Ja, mega. Und jetzt wirfst du die Festplatte aus. Wo sind diese Dateien jetzt? Weil wenn du dann auf den Papierkorb klickst, sind die nicht mehr da. Aber die sind ja noch irgendwo. Ja, vor allem, ich finde, eine Festplatte bräuchte einen eigenen Papierkorb auf der Festplatte. Mich macht das nämlich wahnsinnig. So genau wie im Badezimmer, wo du auch einen eigenen Mülleimer brauchst. Ich finde auch. Also eine Festplatte braucht keinen schwarzen Mülleimer. Mit Deckel. Ich finde, das braucht die, weil ich weiß immer nicht, ja, zieht das jetzt die rüber und löscht die automatisch? Generell, manchmal, das ist eh messy alles. Seitdem ich erfahren habe, dass ja auch Dinge nicht wirklich gelöscht werden können, sondern die einfach nur so weird überschrieben werden, ja, da wird einfach eine Eins dazwischen geschrieben oder sowas und dann sind die Dateien wie weg. Ja, weil angenommen, also wenn du die Festplatte wieder ansteckst, sind die Dateien wieder im Papierkorb. Aber wenn du jetzt die Festplatte an einen anderen Laptop anschliessst, sind die dann bei dem anderen auch im Papierkorb oder nicht? Weil dann könntest du ja den Vollmüllen sozusagen. Also hast du deinen Müll im Rucksack? Nimm deinen Müll mit erstmal, wenn du im Wald bist und da deinen Keks packen. Wie es im Wald hineinschallt, wirf den Müll. Genau, nimm deinen Müll mit. Du kannst ihn nicht einfach liegen lassen. Und so nimmt die Festplatte auch ihren Müll mit. Wenn die geht, wenn du bei jemandem zu Gast bist, zum Beispiel, ich komme jetzt zu dir und bringe die Tüte Chips mit, die Tüte Chips wird verzerrt, dann nehme ich die Tüte ja wieder mit. Wem gehört der Müll jetzt? Das ist deine Frage. Nein, die Frage will ich nicht nochmal beantworten müssen. Ich glaube, wenn du mit einer externen Festplatte, wenn du die anschliessst, ziehst Dateien in den Mülleimer, löscht die Festplatte dieser Dateien auf der Festplatte. Und wo sind die jetzt? Im Mülleimer. Auf der Festplatte des Laptops? Auf der Festplatte des Laptops. Und wenn ich die Festplatte dann an einem anderen Laptop anschließe, sind die nicht mehr da. Nicht mehr da. Finde ich frech.
Glaube ich aber auch nicht. Weil dann müsste ein aufwendiger Kopiervorgang, Papierkorb-Kopiervorgang gestartet worden sein. Das ist ja ganz unangenehm, wenn du von einem Mülleimer Dinge in einen anderen Mülleimer transportieren musst. Also angenommen, dein Küchenmülleimer ist voll, du hast aber keine Lust, den Müll runterzutragen, Also nimmst du den Küchenmüll und wirfst ihn in deinen Wohnzimmermülleimer, um in der Küche mehr Platz zu haben. Hast du jetzt auch überall Mülleimer? Ja, klar. Ich bin tatsächlich weg von Mülleimern. Ich habe mittlerweile, ne, lass mich kurz erklären, dein skeptischer Blick, deine Faust ist schon erhoben, die Augenbraue zittert schon ein bisschen vor Wut. Ich bin ja komplett umgestiegen auf, ich habe nur noch Tüten. Ich habe keinen Mülleimer mehr, ich habe nur noch die Tüte. Und die Tüte liegt als Tüte in der Küche. Gut, du hast einfach Ästhetik weg in den Papierkorb gelegt. Richtig, richtig. Deine Ästhetik ist in the bin. Ich habe den dünnen Film Zivilisation abgeworfen. Das brauchst du aber nicht so stolz sagen. Weil wenn du dich von der Ästhetik abgewandt hast, ist jetzt bei dir alles möglich. Jetzt kannst du alle Grenzen neu denken. Jetzt ist alles egal. Ich habe den Mülleimer entsorgt. Ich habe gesagt, brauche ich nicht mehr. Alle Grenzen des modernen
Wohnens hast du überwunden.
Aber du hast auch die Schönheit überwunden.
Weil ich versuche jetzt, ich versuche auch ein bisschen
bewusster zu leben, indem
ich zum Beispiel, wenn ich irgendeine Tüte
habe, die Müll ist, aber es ist keine Mülltüte,
mache ich sie zur Mülltüte.
Beispiel.
Haben alle ohne Beispiel perfekt verstanden.
Aber gib uns ein Beispiel. Ich hole mir einen schönen
KFC-Eimer. Der wird verzehrt. Den schiebe ich mir rein. Du machst den Eimer zum Mülleimer. Richtig. Jetzt ist der Eimer, in dem ja erst fettiges Gut war, Grillgut, Frittiergut, Frittart, was ja kein Müll ist. Achtung! Sondern Nahrung. Obwohl, streng genommen, du veränderst nichts daran. Du nimmst nur etwas weg und schon wird es zum Müll. Lass da mal drüber nachdenken. Ist der Knochen schon Müll, bevor ich den Wing gegessen habe? Und dann wird die Fespa rausgezogen und wo ist der Wing jetzt? Das ist alles messy. Was ich sagen will, ist, die Knochen sind dann im Eimer und im Sprichwörtlichen im Eimer. Und dann sind einfach, mache ich es zum Mülleimer? Mein Gott, ich darf mir den Schleunen nicht so dumm an. Ich mache den KFC-Eimer, da tue ich dann auch anderen Müll rein. Ich habe mir eine Frage gestellt. Vor allem ist das schon so ein Mülleimer. Oh mein Gott, jeden Scheiß muss man dir erklären. Du guckst mich immer an wie so ein Pudel. Immer so ein, ich traue mich nicht zu sagen, dass ich es nicht verstanden habe, erklär es mir bitte. Du, vor allem, das Beste ist, du hast den ersten Schritt schon überwunden, du musst den ja gar nicht mehr als Mülleimer machen, in dem Moment wo Knochen drin sind, Essensreste drin sind, ist es ja schon ein Mülle. Ob der Eimer jetzt will oder nicht, ob du willst oder nicht, du hast schon Mülleimer. Ab welchem Punkt? Wenn 60 Prozent Knochen, 60 Prozent frittiertes Grillgut-Fritat ist verzehrt worden. Ja, aber jetzt mal ein anderes Beispiel. Ein Schüsselchen Pistazien und du nimmst die Pizzazien raus und knibbelst die Schale ab. Wenn du dich wieder da reinlegst. Und tust die Schale wieder in die Schale. Oh mein Gott, dann ist da das Ende unserer Beziehung. Stopp, jetzt haben wir ein Problem. Du tust die Schale in die Schale. Was meine ich? Du tust die Pistazienschale in, also in die Pistazienschale. Was meine ich? Oh mein Gott. Du tust die Hülle der Pistazie in das Geschirr. Pistazienschale, was meine ich? Oh mein Gott. Du hast die Hülle der Pistazie in das Geschirr.
Pistazienschale.
Ja.
Okay, ich mal den Bild.
Nein, den weiss mir nicht auf.
Ich hole einen Zettel.
Alles klar.
Nein, du musst.
Und ab welchem Punkt wird die Schale zur Müllschale, ergo die noch vollen Pistazien werden zum Müll. Wann kippt's? Wann kippt's? Für mich ist es schon ab dem Moment gekippt, wo du die erste Schale in die vollen Pistazienschale reingeballert hast. Das ist schon die Ursünde. Das ist die Ursünde und da fängt das Problem an. Da fängt dann das ganze Paradoxon, was du gerade versuchst aufzumalen an. Nee, das darfst du auch nicht machen. Ich kenne auch jemanden, der tut Popcornkörner wieder in die Popcorntüte. Wie gesagt, das ist das dümmste, was ich in meinem Leben je gehört habe. Weil du nicht nur verschiebst du das Problem, weil du den Kern wieder isst, sondern im Laufe des Abends steigt die Kerndichte in deiner Popcorn-Tüte und es wird immer schlimmer.
Es strebt gegen unendlich.
Aber er ist wahrscheinlich in seinem Leben schon mal es geschafft, Popcorn aufzuessen, ist ja irgendwann nicht mehr möglich.
Irgendwann kommst du ja aus der Spirale nicht mehr raus.
Ja, das ist jetzt die Frage.
Eigentlich ja, doch eigentlich schon.
Das ist ja dieses mit der Schildkröte und Achilles Ding, dass wenn du immer die Hälfte des Weges gehst, irgendwann hast du es geschafft. Also angenommen, du hast jetzt ein Glas Apfelsaft, trinkst die Hälfte und füllst dann immer wieder mit Wasser auf. Ich glaube, wenn du immer die Hälfte des Weges gehst, brauchst du unendlich lang. Nee, Achilles überholt ja die Schildkröte faktisch. Probleme, die sind aufgekommen, wurden von der Menschheit. Niemand versteht mehr, worum es geht gerade. Doch, ganz kurz. Wenn du immer wieder ein nicht gepopptes Popcorn erwischst und es wieder in die Popcorn-Schale hast. Erhöhst du die Wahrscheinlichkeit, wieder einen Kern zu bekommen. Ist es so wie jemand, der immer nur die Hälfte des Weges geht? Weil du erhöhst die Chance wieder, dass man wieder nur ein umgepopptes Popcorn-Ding holt. These, du brauchst unendlich lange um die Pop Popcorn aufzuessen, was ja eigentlich ganz geil ist.
Weil du hast ja eigentlich viel Popcorn.
Ja, stimmt schon.
Deswegen ist diese Wegmetapher falsch, weil da willst du ja ans Ziel kommen.
Wenn du immer die Hälfte des Weges gehst, meiner Meinung nach kommst du nicht ans Ziel.
Gut, ist deine Meinung, kann die jetzt niemand nehmen, du beharrst darauf.
Ich sag, die Erfahrung zeigt, dass es schon so ist.
Ich find's gut, dass das Problem aufgekommen ist in der Geschichte der Menschheit, es gelöst wurde und ich dir in Frage stelle. Ja, genau. I ist nicht gleich mc², das ist meine Meinung. Und dann geht so ein Raunen durch die Wissenschaft und alle sagen, es hat sich niemand getraut, in Frage zu stellen. Raunen? Ja, aber auch, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hui, hu jeder hat eine andere Geschwindigkeit, hätten alle die exakt selbe Geschwindigkeit, würde das Stück enden und alle machen gleichzeitig. Ja, und das ist so weird, aber der Trend geht ja dahin, dass sich das angleicht und am Ende klatten alle rhythmisches Klatschen. Furchtbar, immer furchtbar. Aber das ist doch mal ein Sketch, also nicht ein Sketch, sondern was für unsere Timeout-Show mit Dings.
Der meldet sich nicht, Guido Kahnnes meldet sich nicht, ich schreibe dem einen Mail nach der anderen, meldet sich nicht. Aber das ist doch mal ein Sketch. Also nicht ein Sketch, sondern was für unsere Time-Out-Show mit Dings.
Wer meldet sich nicht, Guido, du kannst es, meldet sich nicht.
Ich schreibe dem einen Mail nach dem anderen, meldet sich nicht.
Prank, ja, irgendjemand soll
geprankt werden, jetzt hier Igor
Levit oder sowas, soll geprankt werden,
der Pianist. Ja.
Und dann sagt man, okay,
das ganze Konzertsaal ist voller Pranks da.
So, nach dem Konzert.
Nach dem Konzertsaal ist voller Prankster. So, nach dem Konzert. Nach dem Konzert. Und der gesamte Saal hängt rhythmisch gleichzeitig. Und dann fände ich es lustig, wenn alle so gucken, so, oh fuck, wir kommen jetzt aus dem Rhythmus wieder raus, dann versuchen alle, schneller zu werden. So, dann die Frage, wie lange wird es dauern, bis Igor Levit aufsteht und geht? Bis Igor Levit auf die Zugabe verzichtet und irritiert rausgeht. Und das Geld kriegt es so als Kinderdörfer. In dem Moment, in dem das Stück aufhört, fängt die Uhr an und dann ist die Frage, wie lange dauert es, bis er geht oder bis er sich ein Lächeln nicht verkneifen kann. Also würde er die Absurdität der Situation bemerken? Wir wissen es nicht. Ja, die Uhr hört auf, sobald er die Absurdität der Situation in einer Tat ummünzt. Beispiel gehen. Ja, wisst du genau? Das ist unser Pitch, dann eins. Guido Kanz sitzt Kopfschüttel in der letzten Reihe, verschränkte Arme, der vierte Pinch, den er heute hören muss von uns. Keiner hat ihm richtig zugesagt. Ich sag nur, mega Idee, das ist eine mega Idee. Aber wo finden wir so viele Prankster, dass wir einen ganzen Konzertsaal damit füllen können? Gab es in Deutschland nicht genug Prankster? Ich glaube, das ist ein großes Problem. Ja, wo ist unser Prankster? Deutschland seine Prankster, wo sind die Prankster?
Wo ist der Nachwuchs, frage ich mich. Wo ist die Lugosi-Johann? Simon Gosi-Johann?
Ja? Wo ist Simon Gosi-Johann? Wo sind die neuen Leute? Wo sind die neuen Leute?
Wo ist der Prankster-Studiengang leer, geähnende Lehre? Nur halt irgendwie, ha ha ha, ich tue so, als wäre ich der Dozent, bin ich nicht.
So, geil, aber wenn keiner da ist, ist es halt auch nur
halblustig. Halblustig.
Aber immer nur sehr lustig.
Ich weiß nicht. Prankster
müssen wir wieder heranziehen. Wir müssen wieder mit einer Prankster-Schule.
Clownsschulen gibt es.
Wo sind die Prankster-Schulen? Kann man eigentlich
einfach eine Schule aufmachen? International School
of Comedy? Wir machen die auf.
Ich glaube, da fängt es an. Also da hört es auf.
International. Ich glaube, erstmal nicht International. Gut, National. National School of Comedy? National School of Comedy. Ich glaube, da fängt es an. Da hört es auf. International. Ich glaube, erst mal nicht international. National School of Comedy. National School of Comedy. NCS. NSC. Mit freundlichen Grüßen. Die National School of Comedy. Lehrgänge, Stand-up, Prank, Sketch und Mails. Lustige Mails. Wir haben ganz viele Mails bekommen zum Thema. Wir haben ja letzte Woche ein weiteres Mal eine Million Dollar Idee gehabt zum Thema niemand will anrufen, niemand will telefonieren, also haben wir einen SMS-Dienst eingerichtet, an den ihr eine SMS schicken könnt für 1,99 Euro mit dem Inhalt, bitte reserviere mir einen Friseurtermin am Donnerstag zwischen 16 und 19 Uhr. Genau, hier ist eine FAQ, falls folgende Rückfragen kommen. Genau, hier ist das Telefonat, wir nehmen dir das Telefonat ab und schicken dir den Termin. Stellt sich raus, wer hat unsere Idee geklaut? Google! Echt? Die Schweine von Google haben unsere Idee geklaut und zwar... Sofort, am nächsten Tag. Ja, und zwar haben die eine KI entwickelt, die an Orten anrufen kann und Termine aushandeln kann. Und das ist unfassbar. So, wir rufen jetzt Google an. Jeder weiß die Handynummer von Google. Weißt du die? Eins? Ja, glaub schon. Aber eins.
Irgendwann sind wir anrufen.
Schaut euch das an.
AI, Phonecall, Google findet ihr auf Clipfish oder Vimeo oder wo auch immer.
Oder auf Google.
Oder auf Google, ja, könnt ihr mit einer Suchmaschine eurer Wahl, könnt ihr raussuchen dieses Ergebnis.
Es ist toll auf jeden Fall.
Klar, in so Präsentationen weiß man nie, ob diese KI wirklich eine KI ist oder ob die das gescriptet haben oder so. Eine Horde Inder. Die Schlagzeile fehlt noch. KI war von Anfang an eine Horde Inder. Ist nicht ein bisschen rassistisch, wenn wir Horde schreiben? Ne, ne, das geht schon. Schreibt das so, schreibt das so. Und es ist ein tolles Video auf jeden Fall, das uns in vielfacher Ausführung zugeschickt wurde, wo das tatsächlich geht, wo tatsächlich Leute von einem Friseur oder so mit einer KI sprechen und das wahrscheinlich nicht merken. Aber wie unangenehm, aber es ist auch unangenehm, da hinzukommen, weil das Schöne ist ja, wie man Sport gemacht hat, diese Momente danach, dieses Auflegen, das ist geschafft, das Wecklicken bei der To-Do-App und so dann hinzufahren, dann bringt man es hinter sich und so. Jetzt hast du aber so eine KI vorgeschickt, so ein bisschen peinlich und dann kommst du da an und vielleicht hatte die KI auch ein paar, vielleicht gab es so ein paar Missverständnisse oder so und steht da plötzlich irgendwie so ja, du bestellst Getränk oder so beim Friseur, steht plötzlich vor. Ja, so ein Mocker. Was ist das eigentlich? Haben Sie doch Mocker bestellt. Vor allem, der ruft halt dann immer, also bei einem ersten Anruf war es eine weibliche Stimme, die dann sagt, I'm calling for a client. Also, das heißt, du wirst erstmal angekündigt als ein krasser Typ, der eine Assistentin hat. Und nun spricht zu Ihnen König Stephan. Meine Lord und Lords und Ladies, wir präsentieren Stephan. Der Unglaubliche, der Verteidiger von Wien, Stephan. Ja, okay, und dann klingt Kling Kling. Er könnte es einrichten am folgenden Montag um 16 Uhr. Da haben wir keinen Termin mehr frei. Am nächsten Dienstag gegen 14 Uhr bei ihm zu sein. Ja, ist ganz schlecht, nur getönt oder föhnt oder 15 Uhr. Haarschnitt oder färben oder ein Haarschnitt dürfte reichen. Gut, ja, also die Woche ist komplett voll leider. Danke! Dann braucht halt die KI eine schlechtere KI. Ja, genau. Eine weniger gut bezahlte KI. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall die Zukunft, das heißt, wir haben mal wieder die Zukunft vorhergesehen und sorry. Wir haben die Vergangenheit vorhergesehen, wahrscheinlich, weil es schon vorher kam. Was eigentlich noch viel schwerer ist, wenn man sich mal ganz ehrlich ist. Wenn man mal lügt. Was wir ja tatsächlich, ja, wenn man mal unehrlich ist, dann ja, es ist schwieriger. Es ist schwieriger. Aber gibt es tatsächlich, Google arbeitet schon an unseren Ideen.
Aber das beruhigt mich ein bisschen, dass wir hier nicht die Vordenker sein müssen.
Weil manchmal denkt man auch, wenn wir diese Idee gehabt hätten und die wären noch nicht irgendwo in Arbeit, würde ich mir denken, Hupsala, würde ich mir denken.
Wir sind offensichtlich vielleicht zu clever und sollten vielleicht nicht das Potenzial, unser Potenzial verschmettern, indem wir hier diesen Podcast machen, sondern wir sollten bei Google Google setzen und Ideen generieren. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, hast, fuck, ich muss jetzt hier die guten Ideen liefern, dann denkst du, fuck, die Welt ist nicht gut. Richtig, Woody Allen will nicht in einen Club, der ihn aufnehmen will, so geht es uns. Wir wollen nicht in einer Welt leben, die uns als Vordenker braucht.
Richtig. Und die Geschichte gehört ja erfahrungsgemäß eher den Nachdenkern. Also Tesla oder so. Tesla-Edison, die waren ja die, die von den eigentlichen Entwicklern das geklaut haben. Das sind dann wir. Wir lassen Google mal vorrennen und so ein bisschen das Kielwasser. Wir sind im Kielwasser von Google und am Ende ziehen wir vorbei, hauen wir nochmal schön einen blauen Panzer kurz vor der Ziellinie auf Google und dann ziehen wir vorbei und Google haut den Controller gegen die Wand und oh, und wir fahren davon. Mama, Mama, und wir so, nee. Nee, die Banane gehört genauso zum Spiel, mein Sohn. So, und dann ihr versteht schon, was ihr meint, oder? Gibt es denn zu einer anderen Storyline gewisse Updates? Es gibt Updates, aber die kann ich tatsächlich hier nicht erzählen. Die kann ich dir in unserem freundschaftlichen Nachschnack erzählen. What? Wie spannend ist das denn? Es gab tatsächlich ein Eklat bei mir auf der Strasse, der tatsächlich strafrechtlich schadwäckige Nachwirkungen hat. Und ich war da nicht nur so halb involviert, ich war eigentlich nur Beistender, Beisteher, Nebensteher. Und von daher kann ich da momentan nicht drüber reden. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall chaotisch geworden. Das ist ein Twist, den ich nie habe. Es ist auf jeden Fall chaotisch geendet, aber... Es ist chaotisch geendet? Die Kiosk-Leckermade-Storyline ist chaotisch geendet? Es hat einen unerwarteten Twist und dann nochmal einen unerwarteten Twist genommen. Aber egal, irgendwann kann ich das aufklären. Es ist auf jeden Fall merkwürdig. Es ist auch nicht so wichtig jetzt. Okay. So, dann war es das. Sorry, dass wir schon wieder mit einer Enttäuschung.
Woche mit dem Podcast-UFO. Wir wünschen euch halt jedenfalls eine spannenderere Woche als dieses Ende der Podcast-UFO-Folge.
Ja, passt auf euch auf und guckt mal, was läuft.
In diesem Sinne, ja, okay.
Ciao.
Dann tschüss, wir, äh, heben ab.
Heben ab.
Ja, jetzt, jetzt wo ist es.